in this video we'll be talking about
cycling and cdk and their role in cell
cycle regulation this is a slightly
longer video please stay tuned till the
end it would be highly beneficial and
high yielded so what are cyclines
cyclines are proteins that undergo
cyclical pattern of synthesis and
degradation hence they are known as
cyclines so in certain stage of the cell
cycle they are produced and in certain
stage of the cell cycle they are
degraded so they appearance or their
activity is restricted in a Time bound
fashion and this is how they are named
as cycling because their levels rise and
fall in a coordinated manner with the
progression of the cell cycle and what
are cdk cdk are cycline dependent kyes
so they are obviously kyes molecules
which are capable of phosphila but they
are highly dependent on their partner
which is cycline it's like they are a
couple so without cycling cdk cannot
perform any work so that is why they are
highly dependent on each other so cyclan
cdk act together as a unit this is the
take-home message anyway there are
important functions which are regulated
by cdks at a structural level they are
serenon KES so basically they're going
to phosphorate serin oronine residues in
the Target protein their activity is
dependent on binding to the cyclines so
without the cycl they are nothing C
regulate the cell progression by
phosphila several Target proteins that
modulate events of the cell cycle and
ultimately the activity of the cycline
cdk complex is tightly regulated by
several kinases and phosphatase
action so let's look at the cyclan cdk
which are active in different stages of
the cell cycle in the G1 phase the most
active cycling is cycan D and cdk46
complex in S phase cyclan e and cdk2
complexes are active at the end of S
phase cyclan a and cdk2 complexes are
active and in the M phase the key
cycling that takes important role is
cyclan B cdk1 in this video we would try
to elaborate on each of these cycling
and their activity so most important
cycline is cyclan d cyclan e and cyclan
B in a moment it will be clear so let's
talk about the G1 cyclan or cdk complex
which is known as cyclan D cdk46 complex
let's see what this complex is capable
of doing so cyclan D and cdk6 complex is
getting activated with when there are
ample amount of growth factor signaling
now cyclan D is directly produced in
response to mitogenic signaling or
growth factor signaling so it kind of
tells the cell whether growth factor is
present in the environment or not if it
is present in the environment then
cyclin D would be produced The Complex
would be active for example we know that
mapin is pathway is triggered by growth
factor binding so obviously one of the
key Downstream Gene that gets activated
in the RAS RAF Arc pathway is the cyclan
D it is one of the most abundant Target
Gene in this pathway so cyclan D is
produced uh Downstream to the growth
factor signaling and now it's important
to note that whether to divide or not to
divide is a very critical decision that
cell has to make because it is totally
energy dependent processes like DNA
replication happening in SASE chromosome
segregation happening in the mhase all
of these things requires a hell lot of
energy so if nutrients are not present
then it is not a appropriate time to
divide so there is a particular point in
the cell cycle known as restriction
point where cycline D cdk4 take critical
decision they took took all the
information from growth factor signaling
nutrient availability and stress factor
based on all of these they decide
whether cell should cross restriction
point or they should not cross if
restriction point is crossed then it has
to divide so there is no point to back
out anyway that is why cyclan D cdk4
activity is really
important now I'll tell you that how prb
which is particularly a tumor supressor
protein act to modulate the cycline D
cdk4 activity or Cy and how basically
prb regulate the cell cycle progression
so basically it's a tumor suppressor
protein it would suppress the growth it
is produced by rb1 Gene which produce
the rb1 MRNA and translates into prb
protein now prb protein acts in the
Restriction point now it's important to
note that how prb works so prb is a
critical decision decision maker prb can
actually inhibit a compound known as e2f
e2f is really important for cell cycle
progression to S phase because e2f can
selectively bind to the DNA and e2f can
help to produce the um SASE cycling but
e2f is only able to do that when prb let
it be separated right so when prb is
separated from the e2f complex e2f can
do its job
so that is why separating e2f is really
important now here is cycling e
production that happens when e2f binds
to the DNA cyclan e mRNA is produced and
cyclan E is produced and this is really
important for replication progression
but here is our inhibitor prb because
prb sequesters the e2f and don't let it
bind to the DNA so who would tell prb to
back off and this critical job is done
by cycling D and cdk 4 if the
environment is favorable growth factor
is present cell has enough nutrient then
cycl D and cdk4 would phosphorate prb
and phosphila prb allow it to be removed
from the e2f complex so it is De
inhibiting the e2f complex and basically
e2f complex is now free to bind to the
DNA and allow the cell cycle to progress
from G1 to the S phase this is how cycan
D and cdk uh 4 as well as cyclan
eproduction is really important in this
G G1 and S boundary so now we understand
its
highlight okay now there is another
protein another tumor suppressor which
can modulate cycline CD can thereby
regulate cell cycle this is p53 It's a
tumor suppressor protein it plays key
role in cell cycle regulation apoptosis
and maintenance of the genomic stability
it can actually pause the cell cycle
progression in many ways but why P 53
should pause cell cycle
why it is important and what is the
consequence so let's see let's say there
is a DNA damage that happened during
let's say G1 phase now if this
particular DNA damage is not repaired
there could be detrimental consequences
because these are really delorious in
terms of uh nature so basically there
could be blockage of the replication
fork there could be loss of a chromosome
segment and the worst outcome is
basically apoptosis or death of the cell
now p-53 can modulate the cycling and
prevent and pause the cell cycle how it
is happening so basically there are
specific sensors known as ATM ATR which
can bind to the DNA damage sense the DNA
damage and with Downstream signaling
Pathways like which involves check 2
p-53 can get activated now normally p53
is degraded but when check to phosphor
at p53 it is activated and p-53 can do
many things it can activate p21 which is
a negative influencer of cyclan cdk
activity now when p21 blocks the cycl
cdk activity cell cycle is paused cell
cycle cannot progress further now you
must be thinking why it is good
sometimes pausing the cell cycle is
important because once the cell cycle is
paused it would give DNA repair
Machinery enough time to repair this
damage there are homologous
recombination mechanism there are
non-homologous enjoining mechanism by
which DNA can be
repaired for argument sake imagine the
DNA is repaired then cell cycle is
resumed and the pause is done and
thereby the cell cycle progression
happens and cell divides now imagine the
cell cycle progression is paused but the
damage was beyond repair it cannot be
repaired in that case cell would be uh
induced for apoptosis so p53 actually
coordinate with caspas 3 and basically
Target the intrinsic pathway of
apoptosis it activates back and bad
which pokes whole in the mitochondrial
membrane basically cytochrome C leaks
out ultimately caspace 3 is activated
which triggers the apoptosis
response now we understand how p53
modulates cycline and thereby modulating
uh basically the cell cycle so basically
one outcome was the damage was repaired
cell survives and go to the cell cycle
another extreme outcome was cell would
die because the damage was irreversible
and instead of of segregating faulty
chromosome it was good to kill the cell
because if this is not prevented it
might lead to tumor formation or sort of
cancer formation and indeed many p53
mutations are associated with cancer
then we move into s-phase cyclines sface
cycl is cyclan e and cdk2 is the
corresponding cdk partner so in this
case let's see how sface cycl helps in
the replication initiation process so in
at the end of G1 the replicator sequence
is is already bound to the origin of
replication complex it also binds to
ctd1 and cdc6 it loads the MCM 27
helices so these helic would form the
replication bubble but that requires a
licensing event that licensing event is
happening with the help of kinases
cycling dependent kinases so there are
two events replications replicator
selection and there is another event
which is origin activation this origin
activation is the license ing event that
has to happen but who gives the license
in S phase the cyclan E and cdk2
activity is high so this particular
complex can actually phosphorate these
ctd1 cdc6 and thereby allow the
replication bubble to
form so it's important to note that this
replication bubble forms at the
beginning of the S phase and in any
other stage since these particular
components cdt1 cdc6 all of them are
hyper phosphor dilated then what happens
is they cannot get reassembled into the
replication complex thereby it also
ensures that replication only happens
once in the cell cycle so this is a big
achievement of the cycling cdk complex
it ensures that replication happens only
once in eukaryotic cell cycle and it
never happens twice and this is the
mechanism anyway you can watch the
detailed video video on eukariotic
replication to know it better anyway
it's important to note that in this
replication initiation as well cycline e
cdk2 complex has huge contribution then
we talk about the mphase cycline which
is cyclan B cdk1 cyclan B cdk1 has
different phosphorilation sites such as
tronin 14 3in 15 are inhibitory sites
3in 161 is activatory site several
kinases like V1 kyes inhibitor perform
inhibition with the help of
phosphorilation there are also activat
KES such as cines there are also
activatory phosphatases which remove
this phos inhibitory phosphorilation and
allow this particular cycl 2 gets
activated anyway when cyclan B and cdk1
complex is activated it can lead to many
biological function like chromosome
condensation nuclear envelope back
breakdown fragmentation of Golgi spindle
appar spindle apparatus formation Etc
anyway after its job is done it would be
degraded with the help of
polyubiquitination by anaphes promoting
complex when poly uation marks are added
onto the cycline B they are destined to
be degraded by proteosome mediated
degradation
anyway cyclan B and cdk1 are really
important kyes because in the beginning
of the prophase cyclan B cdk1 phosphates
the lamins which are the intermediate
filaments supporting the nuclear
envelope so it leads to breakdown of the
nuclear envelope so once the nuclear
envelope is broken down the nucleus gets
basically uh separated and the
chromosomes get slowly condensed so
lamin dissociation is a important event
performed by cyclan B cdk1 second thing
is it can phosphorate condensins
condensins a structural maintenance of
chromosome proteins which basically
condense the chromosome this is how
cyclan B cdk1 complex plays vital role
in packaging and uh condensing the
chromosome at the onset of the m
phase I hope this video was useful we
talked about the G1 the S and the mphase
cycling how they work and how they
regulated get more notes and flash card
in our Instagram and Facebook page you
can support our video with uh super
thanks you can pay via PTM PayPal or UPI
see you in next
video